Speaker 1: Let's go next to Shane from
State College is that is that
State College, Pennsylvania.
Is yes. OK. Yeah, I don't know how it is
that is the town called State College,
I never understood it.
Speaker 4:
Yeah, it's it's the, I guess, the main
campus for Penn. Penn State University
in the town is called State College.
Speaker 1: Fascinating. All right. Well,
what's going on?
Speaker 4:
Not much pleasure to speak with you really
enjoy the show. I have a quick question.
Would you ever consider doing a longform
discussion with Jordan Peterson? I know
you and he have a lot of disagreements. I think
it'll be fascinating to hear you. Two Go back
and forth for a couple of hours.
Speaker 1: Sure. He's been on
before and he's welcome back any time.
Speaker 4: OK. I think that would be I think a
lot of people would benefit from from seeing that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, I guess I'd be too
big for the David Pakman show now. I don't
know that he would do it, quite frankly. Oh,
is that right? Yeah, I mean, I don't know, I don't
think there's a guarantee that Peterson needs,
needs or wants to appear on my show right now.
Speaker 4: And I guess the other question with
that is, what are your current thoughts on
the Iaw and what do you say about? Because
I've read different forums and things and
some people have placed you in that crowd.
What do you think of them and what's going on?
Speaker 1: Oh, yeah, I don't know anything about
that, but I honestly haven't thought of, thought
about or seen anything about the intellectual dark
web for, I would say, a year or longer. I don't
know. I don't know if it still exists. I just have
no idea whatsoever. I mean, do they are they still
have they disbanded? Was it ever really banded?
I just have no idea, it seems. Correct me if
I'm wrong, but it seems as though the relevance
and number of mentions have declined dramatically.
Speaker 4: That's what I've noticed as well, and I
didn't even think it was a formal group, I thought
it was just sort of like a loose collection
of similar kind of thinkers and whatnot. Now
I know, and I haven't heard you talk about
this guy very much, but I don't know if you've
been following Bret Weinstein and The Dark Horse
podcast and some of the things that
they've been saying over there.
Speaker 1: No, I have. I'm aware of the,
you know, spike protein is cytotoxic phase
and the ivermectin is fantastic phase and all of
these different. I am aware of what's going on,
but I've taken mostly a Sam Harris
approach where it's very hard to really
like go point counterpoint because they kind
of put out a fire hose of stuff. And if they
mention one thing you're not prepared for or can
immediately refute, it comes off as though they're
really making good points. And so, you know,
for similar reasons. As Sam Harris has stated,
I'm not like super directly engaging with it.
Speaker 4: That that kind of corresponds with
my take on it as as well, because I did actually
follow the the podcast he and his wife did
for a while, but then as time wore on, I just
found that I wasn't resonating with what they were
saying quite as much, and I had to do
a lot more kind of digging to really.
Kind of see if what they were saying squared
with, you know what the vast majority of other
experts were saying. And eventually I
just decided that they weren't for me.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's fair. That's completely
fair. Everybody should make informed decisions
about media consumption. I'm glad you did.
Speaker 4: Absolutely. Well, I think
that's it for me, but real of the show,
support what you're doing. Thank you very
Speaker 1: much. My pleasure. Thank you so much
for the call. We're going to take just a very
brief break, but we're going to continue the
calls. So if you're holding on to talk to me,
unless you're furious at how long you've been
holding and are about to hang up in a rage,
just hold on another moment and we're going to
go right back to the Discord lines in a second.